the only comedian I watch is nor
McDonald the lake great nor McDonald he
he sadly died too young but I know there
are other comedians out there so my
producers want to introduce me to a new
one Anthony jelnick take it away I don't
like
racism thank
[Applause]
you I don't get
it why would you hate why would you
choose to hate why would you you choose
to hate an entire group of
people just because of the way they all
behave you could see the bunch line
coming
but all right so is he is he like one of
us is he kind of on the let's see let's
see the next one I remember when I was
13 my mom got diagnosed with Parkinson's
and my dad just gave up immediately said
I can't deal with the this I can't live
like this and packed up his car so as a
13-year-old boy I had to be the one to
roll up my sleeves and say
okay guess I'm going with
Dad sounds like Mom needs some alone
time he pretty he's got a good delivery
cuz he's very still he's got he's got a
very good stage presence kind of funny
you know look to compare anyone to the
greatest standup comedian of all time
it's it's impossible to tools ER but
okay let's keep going man my parents are
strict my mom and dad once made me smoke
an entire pack of cigarettes an entire
pack of cigarettes in one sitting just
to teach me an important lesson about
brand
loyalty his structure seems to be pretty
consistent I'd go see this guy I'd go
see him live maybe there's some hope cuz
the thing is now you if you tune in if
I've Had The Misfortune of tuning into
to some comedians who occasionally up
and they're not funny at all and the
best of them are merely not funny and
the worst of them are intensely anti-
funny and their observations are
contrary to reality and the the things
they pose as in congruities or not in
congruities and they don't support
expectations this guy I'm there I'm in
I'd buy a ticket you think I ever got
over my grandmother's death when I was a
kid my grandmother died from a heart
attack during my ninth birthday party
and I guess that must have screwed me up
a little bit you know I mean
I still have birthday
parties but now I'm just careful what I
wish
for yeah that's I also find I prefer
older comedians you get a horse and live
in the mountain someplace and don't
bother anybody yeah there plenty of
young comedians are good in their own
way but I prefer like older grizzled
comedians or tend to be a little funnier
and have obviously worked on their their
craft but okay right now go to jus
cell.com /ns YT letter y letter T I have
got a Christmas gift idea that is sure
to make you the hero of the season and
we all know the holiday season can be a
little bit hectic the shopping the
cooking the long list of things to do if
you're not because I've discovered a
gift that is both thoughtful and
transformative the gift of Jus cell
skincare from now until Christmas Jus
cell's most popular package has a
special discount just for our listeners
at Jus cell.com letter y letter T treat
yourself and your loved ones to the
absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles fine
line skin redness sagging jaw line will
disappear right before your eyes with
jus cell's most popular collection genus
cell promises immediate effects you will
see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back their
products use the best stuff out there on
the market the prices are incredibly
competitive and in fact they will give
you special holiday discounts because
they know even if they lose money on
this order they know that you are going
to keep coming back that is how good it
is go to Jus cell.com
nsyt get this incredible holid discount
today every order is instantly upgraded
to free express shipping j.com nsyt
today he's also not vulgar he's pretty
pretty clean and it's still very funny
okay next one she got mad at me she got
mad at me cuz I killed all of her plants
killed every single one of her house
plants and she had told me she said
Anthony I'm going out of town for 2
weeks give each one of these half a cup
of water every other day but I'm a dude
all I heard was two weeks and cheat on
me that's pretty good now comes the part
where we throw our heads back and laugh
ready I was in a bar last night saw this
beautiful woman like a supermodel I
walked up I was like hey where you from
what do you do she goes oh me I live
here in San Francisco I'm a brain
surgeon now I don't know if this makes
me sexist but I was like really
impressed you know I mean most women
can't pull off
sarcasm they're really they're really
intentionally written there's there
seems like there's very little riffing
going on it's all very very tight which
I guess is why it all fits in these
little tick tocky YouTube shorts kind of
bits one of my next door neighbors is a
90-year-old man suffering from
Alzheimer's and every single morning at
9:00 a.m. he knocks on my door and he
asks me me if I have seen his wife I
have to explain to a 90-year-old man
suffering from Alzheimer's that his wife
has been dead for quite some time now I
have thought about
moving I have thought about just not
answering my door in the morning but to
be
honest it's worth it just to see the
smile on his
face I thought it was going to be like
he was sleeping with the guy guy's wife
but that's
okay okay
now my best friend's wife is a born
again Christian and we do not get along
at
all the other day she called me up to
yell at me saying I'm a terrible
influence on her husband because he
called her a bad name I said what did he
call you a
she said no Anthony
he did not use the b
word I said
uhoh did he call you
a she said no I said well then he didn't
hear it from
me yeah that's all right there's nothing
funny about
that there's something about his
delivery it's very self-conscious it's
almost like a Daniel TSH different tone
but the same kind of Cadence look I'm
not knocking it would I go see a show
yeah probably is it
uh is it
Norm he's good he's good I'm Michael
nolles see you next time in Milwaukee
Wisconsin a man allowed his 8-year-old
daughter to take the wheel of his car
and an accident ensued that damaged
seven other cars and injured six people
which once again proves my theory women
can't drive
[Applause]
oh